einen schönen guten morgen und
willkommen zu heute live ja erstmals in
ihrer parteigeschichte die ja immerhin
auch schon seit gut 40 jahren wert haben
sich die grünen dafür entschieden einen
eigenen kanzlerkandidaten aufzustellen
aber wird es tatsächlich ein kandidat
oder eine kandidatin
diese frage haben die beiden
parteivorsitzenden annalena baerbock und
robert habeck unter sich ausgemacht wie
es heißt und in wenigen minuten wird der
parteivorstand dann die entscheidung in
dieser frage bekannt geben wir sprechen
darüber mit nicole diekmann zdf
hauptstadt korrespondentin in berlin
hallo nicole angesichts dessen was man
momentan so beobachtet zum beispiel bei
der politischen konkurrenz beide union
ist es ja schon auffällig wie still und
harmonisch das ganze bei den grünen
verläuft da haben also die beiden gesagt
sie einigen sich untereinander und in
wenigen minuten soll das ergebnis
verkündet werden
das ist ja schon eine starke leistung
muss man ja sagen ganz genau das hat
natürlich noch mal diese leistung wurde
nochmal konterkariert durch das du hast
es ja gerade schon angedeutet was ich da
markus söder und armin laschet seit
einer woche liefern wir soll man es
nennen machtkampf schlacht hahnenkampf
stierkampf sind mittlerweile alle
begriffe aufgebraucht von teils selbst
fassungslosen medienschaffenden
journalistinnen die gar nicht glauben
können was da passiert bei den grünen
hat man sich das sehr früh anders
überlegt nämlich dass man das
geräuschlos machen möchte dass man sich
untereinander einigen möchte annalena
baerbock und robert habeck sind ja die
potenziellen weil sie eben an der spitze
der partei stehen und genau da haben
selbst wir neugierigen hauptstadt
journalistinnen es nicht geschafft über
über irgendwelche umwege auch nur eine
silbe jemandem zu entlocken
aus den so genannten kreisen wer ist
denn werden könnte wer die nase vorn hat
ja also auch dass auch das bemerkenswert
also nicht nur friedlich sondern auch
absolut diskret und nichts nach außen
gedrungen wer ist
aus seiner sicht der wahrscheinlichere
kandidat oder eben kandidatin
wenn man sich die grünen genauer
anschaut wäre es folgerichtig wenn es
annalena baerbock ist es ist eine
feministische partei annalena baerbock
hat auch den ersten zugriff
das hat robert habeck auch vor kurzem
noch mal gesagt und bestätigt das heißt
eigentlich per dna alleine schon wäre es
annalena baerbock und es kommt noch ein
weiterer punkt hinzu olaf scholz geht
ins rennen für die spd und wir gehen
jetzt mal davon aus dass es nicht eine
noch größere überraschung als dieses
schmutzige ringen um die kandidatur bei
der union gibt entweder markus söder
oder armin laschet jemand anderes das
halt schon zwei männer gesetzt aus den
anderen parteien die kann es nach innen
kandidaten stellen für dieses jahr für
dieses weiter und da wäre es dann noch
mal logisch folgerichtig wenn die grünen
mit einer frau
wir sprechen gleich weiter nicole wir
wollen uns die beiden protagonisten aber
noch mal vorstellen ladies first
annalena baerbock die schauen uns zuerst
an jonas post bestellt sie uns noch mal
vor
annalena baerbock 40 jahre alt war vor
dem parteivorsitz der grünen abgeordnete
im bundestag
sie hat im gegensatz zu robert habeck
noch keine regierungserfahrung gesammelt
sieht das aber nicht als problem an
in einem interview sagte sie drei jahre
als parteichefin abgeordnete und mutter
kleiner kinder stellen ziemlich
gefragt ist die politikerin auf jeden
fall 2009 10 war sie die häufigste gast
in den großen polit talkshows vom talk
thron gestoßen hat sie damit
ausgerechnet ihren ko-vorsitzenden in
dessen schatten sie anfangs stand
stichwort talkshow berbalk gilt im
vergleich zu ihren kollegen als
redegewandter und inhaltlich besser
informiert vor allem beim grünen kern
thema klimaschutz kann sie mit ihrem
wissen punkten
auch wenn berbalk laut umfragen in der
bevölkerung nicht ganz so beliebt ist
die robert habeck genießt sie in ihrer
partei große unterstützung bei ihrer
wiederwahl zur grünen chefin 2009/10
bekamen die politikerin 97,1 prozent der
stimmen
so ein hohes ergebnis hat er in der
geschichte der verteilt noch niemand
erreicht
ja in wenigen minuten wie gesagt wollen
wir dann auch dann tatsächlich zum
parteivorstand schalten gucken gerade
nochmal auf die aktuelle situation und
sähen dass da noch nichts passiert aber
wir verpassen nichts wir sind also immer
mit einem auge sozusagen am rednerpult
des grünen parteivorstands aber zurück
zur annalena baerbock also jung
dynamisch aber noch keine
regierungserfahrung könnte das zum
problem für sie werden das wird
zumindest im moment diskutiert wenn man
die vor nachteile der beiden
gegeneinander abwägt sie hat tatsächlich
noch nie regiert im gegensatz zu robert
habeck da war ja umweltminister in
schleswig holstein ein paar jahre lang
hat sich dann ruf auch erarbeitet als
ein sehr kompromiss fähiger politiker
das geht im moment ein bisschen unter
das klang ja auch gerade im beitrag an
robert habeck hat sich ein paar
schnitzer geleistet in den vergangenen
jahren angefangen zum beispiel bei
unkenntnis über die pendlerpauschale
dann hat er sich ja irgendwann aus den
sozialen netzwerken zurückgezogen
außerhalb von instagram nachdem ihm auf
twitter
ich war wirklich grobe fehler
unterlaufen worden waren
naja eigentlich war es ein fehler den er
aber im abstand von ich glaube nur drei
monaten wiederholt hat das wiederum wird
ihm dann eben zu lasten gelegt dass er
sich teilweise nicht so im griff hat
dass er sich in die themen nicht so tief
ein gerät aber genau wir haben es ja
gerade schon damit haben wir diese
antwort auf gemacht
es wäre ein riesensprung für annalena
baerbock ja gleich mal ein land zu
regieren sollte sie denn kanzlerin
werden das wird sich natürlich freuen
wenn sie als kandidatin ins rennen geht
alles andere wäre quatsch und dann
gleich ohne regierungserfahrung
das land zu regieren das sagen eben
diejenigen die sich für harbeck
aussprechen spricht extrem gegen
annalena baerbock
glaubst du dass diese überlegungen dann
auch bei der entscheidung eine große
rolle spielen also wenn wie jetzt gerade
da nochmal die union im vergleich nehmen
weil da sind wir nun in der tat die
umfragewerte gerade ein zentraler aspekt
wie sieht es da aus dem vergleich
baerbock habeck trauen die leute auch
annalena baerbock obwohl sie ja auch
erst 40 jahre alt ist also noch relativ
jung an lebenserfahrung
dies ist am zug ich so da die robert
habeck knapp das hat er ja gerade im
beitrag gehört aber insgesamt sind die
zustimmungswerte im moment ja gut sonst
werden die grünen ja auch
größenwahnsinnig wenn sie jetzt dass sie
überhaupt jemanden heute ausstellen um
in ihren um eben um die kandidatur aufs
höchste amt in der regierung ins rennen
zu gehen und diesen vorwurf macht den
grünen niemand also ich habe niemandem
gehört oder gelesen und in den
vergangenen monaten eben in anbetracht
der umfragen der oder die geschrieben
kommentiert oder gesagt hätte was wollen
die grünen denn überhaupt den
kanzlerkandidaten stellen das ist ja
völlig unrealistisch das ist es eben
nicht und das trifft auf beide zu das
trifft auf h weg zu der ein wenig weiter
vorne liegt was die umfragen angeht als
annalena baerbock aber beide haben
zustimmungswerte nicht nur aus der
eigenen partei bei dem man sagen kann ok
es wäre nicht völlig hirnrissig den oder
diejenige heute zu präsentieren ja also
beide mit realistischen chancen dann
gucken wir doch noch auf den anderen
etwas genauer robert habeck nämlich auch
über ihn hat mein kollege jonas
postpress post pesch noch fall ein paar
informationen zusammengetragen
robert habeck 51 jahre alt war mehr als
fünf jahre lang umweltminister und
stellvertretender ministerpräsident in
schleswig holstein
damit bringt ein ordentliches maß
regierungserfahrung mit
nach seiner wahl zum grünen-chef 2018
wurde habe ich schnell über seine partei
hinaus bekannt und beliebt so titelte
der stern im mai 2009 10 robert habeck
unser nächster kanzler doch der hype
hielt nicht lange an
vielleicht auch weil harbeck sich einige
patzer erlaubte so schrieb er einmal auf
twitter er wolle thüringen zu einem
offenen und demokratischen land machen
das wurde ihm als wessi arroganz
ausgelegt haben haben die aussage zurück
der promovierte philosoph robert habeck
ist ein mann großer worte für die
kommende bundestagswahl sagte in einem
interview
man muss es mal aussprechen wir reden
hier über einen moment den lauf der
geschichte zu verändern wenn es um
politische detailfragen geht fällt habe
ich aber immer wieder mit wissenslücken
auf etwa bei der pendlerpauschale oder
der haltung seiner partei zu julian
assange bevor das nicht die freunde doch
ich fordere die freilassung von julian
assange
das merken auch politiker kollegen also
ich glaube dass am ende baerbock wird
weil die sich die sachen wenigstens
durchliest habe da machte spontan alles
und das ist können wir nicht gebrauchen
momentan dennoch in der bevölkerung
glauben mehr menschen an habeck als in
seine ko-vorsitzende annalena baerbock
bei den anhängern der grünen sind die
beiden jedoch gleichauf
tja da waren jetzt mal ganz interessante
aussagen dabei auch von robert habeck wo
er vielleicht so ein bisschen auf dem
falschen fuß erwischt wurde wie stark
fällt das ins gewicht was glaubst du
also wenn du jetzt meine glaskugel fragt
sie habe ich leider nicht ausgepackt
wirklich relativ offenes rennen zwischen
den beiden weil eben wie gesagt beide
bringen gute argumente mit boom
nominiert zu werden heute von ihrer
partei beziehungsweise naja um sich zu
präsentieren als kandidat oder
kandidatin und es gibt auch gewichtige
argumente gegen die beiden nochmal war
annalena baerbock das ist die komplett
nicht vorhandene regierungserfahrung auf
keiner ebene darüber tabak ist es eben
das jetzt ein paarmal
sehr klar wurde dass er sich in
wichtigen fragen nicht eingearbeitet hat
also julian assange ist ein beispiel
aber ich habe es ja eben auch gesagt die
pendlerpauschale und dass die
pendlerpauschale ist eine frage die
betrifft viele millionen menschen in
diesem land und das ist dann peinlich
und das vergessen leute eben und wir
medien wie wir gerade sehen auch nicht
robert habeck hat er im vorfeld gesagt
dass wenn frau baerbock also als frau
diese nummer ist zugreifen würde weil
sie sagt ja ich will das machen dann
habe sie das erstzugriffsrecht und dann
hätte sie sozusagen die pole position
ist es so einfach als würde er so
schnell tatsächlich dann klein beigeben
es ist ja auch für ihn eine historische
chance
ja es ist aber robert habeck hat sicher
vor jahren mal dazu entschieden bei den
grünen einzutreten und dann musste er ja
mit wem er es zu tun hat also feminismus
ist ja kein kein neues thema kein neues
feld dass die grünen jetzt für sich
entdeckt haben sondern das war gehört
zur gründungsgeschichte der grünen
da haben sie sich das schon auch die
fahnen geschrieben deswegen wird ihnen
das jetzt nicht überraschen können was
aber auch zur geschichte gehört ist das
annalena baerbock auch sagt sie wird
nicht nur dann kanzlerkandidatin weil
sie eine frau ist
und ich glaube das sollte das versuchen
manche leute die jetzt stimmung gegen
die grünen machen auch in den sozialen
medien in hwk aussage mit rein zu
schummeln als versteckte nachricht also
wenn sie es wird dann nur weil sie eine
frau ist so ist es dann auch nicht was
die beiden auch voneinander sagen das
kann man nach den vergangenen monaten
tatsächlich auch einigermaßen ernst
nehmen
trotz aller erfahrungen die wir mit dem
schmutzigen geschäft politik haben egal
wer von beiden ist irrt er oder sie kann
sich auf die unterstützung des anderen
oder der anderen voll verlassen
ich gucke gerade noch mal mit einem auge
hier über meinen laptop hinweg weil ich
sehe dass ich da ein bisschen was tut
zumindest bei den grünen da läuft jetzt
ein film wenn ich das richtig sehe
könnte darauf hindeuten dass es gleich
losgeht
ich frage gerade nochmal in die regie da
hab ich gerade was gehört gibt es dann
eine ansage oder noch nicht
also ob er es ist offenbar noch alles in
vorbereitung und wir können noch ein
bisschen weiter sprechen
nicole ich nehme an der stelle gerne
auch unsere user noch mal ein bisschen
mit ins boot david williams oder david
jetzt muss ich doch unterbrechen denn da
sind die beiden wie geben direkt rüber
in der grünen geschichte und auch in
unserer geschichte
wir sind jetzt seit dreieinhalb jahren
eine doppelspitze
es waren gute dreieinhalb jahre gute für
uns gute für die partei wir haben
herausragende wahl erfolge gefeiert
wir haben die partei programmatisch
weiterentwickelt vor allem haben wir
einen neuen führungsstil etabliert ein
stil der auf kooperation aufbaut der
einander raum lässt der das miteinander
nach vorne stellt wir glauben dass hat
der partei gut getan
ich wollte ja immer das macht so
interpretiert wird das führung so gelebt
wird dass man aneinander wächst und sich
nicht gegenseitig die beine weg tritt
ich glaube dass der erfolg der grünen
ganz wesentlich in diesem
führungsverständnis begründet ist nicht
nur der interne erfolg sondern auch dass
wir damit ein gesellschaftliches angebot
unterbreiten konnten
das sind unruhigen zeiten eine andere
idee von politik verkörpert
wir sind trotz der schwierigen phase
wirkende corona zeit stabil geblieben
wir sind erfolgreich geblieben und wir
sind in deutschland das darf man wohl
sagen wir glauben gerade wegen diesem
anderen politikverständnis so etwas wie
der ruhende pol in einer aufgewühlten
politischen landschaft nun hat der
erfolg eine paradoxe seite wir sind in
gewissem sinne durch die gemeinsamkeit
so erfolgreich geworden dass jetzt etwas
passiert was noch vor jahren unmöglich
schien
wir kämpfen um das kanzleramt wir sind
stabil in umfragen 20 prozent die union
ist in reichweite
und in dieser
situation führt der gemeinsame erfolg
dazu dass eine einen schritt
zurücktreten muss annalena baerbock und
ich wir haben in den letzten tagen
wochen und ehrlicherweise eigentlich
jahren immer wieder darüber geredet wie
so was gehen kann wer kanzlerkandidat in
der grünen werden soll
berlin welche argumente für oder gegen
etwas sprechen
wir haben in den letzten tagen und
wochen in vertraulichen vertrauten
intensiven offenen manchmal auch
schwierigen gesprächen miteinander um
die beste lösung gerungen
denn es ist ja klar wir beide haben uns
darauf vorbereitet wir beide wollten ist
aber am ende kann es nur eine machen und
so ist es heute der moment zu sagen dass
die erste grüne kanzlerkandidatin
annalena baerbock sein wird annalena
baerbock ist eine kämpferische
fokussierte willensstarke frau die genau
weiß was sie will und die die grüne
programmatik in diesem wahlkampf mit
leidenschaft vertreten wird sie wird uns
in diesem wahlkampf anführen
das heißt natürlich nicht dass sie den
wahlkampf alleine machen wird ich selbst
werde mich mit allem was ich kann mit
voller kraft in diesen markt werfen
wir werden ihnen versuchen gemeinsam zu
führen aber natürlich ist politik
dynamisch und eine dynamik bedeutet dass
sich rollen immer wieder neu justieren
werden
ich selbst werde in den nächsten phasen
noch stärker als zuvor
meine regierungserfahrung und die
erfahrung von mehrfach erfolgreich
abgeschlossenen koalition zur handlung
nutzen um die partei auf die
regierungsübernahme vorzubereiten
davor allerdings steht ein harter
wahlkampf
wir machen uns keine landschaft so in
aufruhr ist weil sich die gesellschaft
neu findet und neu orientieren muss bis
eine harte wahlauseinandersetzung werden
also vor der regierung steht der
wahlkampf und in diesem wahlkampf wird
uns die erste grüne kanzlerkandidatin
führen
annalena baerbock liebe anna lena bitte
die bühne gehört hier
schönen guten tag auch von meiner seite
robert bei dem was du gerade gesagt hast
habe ich sehr an unserem parteitag vor
drei jahren gedacht und ich glaube viele
andere grüne
auch damals war unser motto und das ist
erst der anfang wir wussten vor drei
jahren natürlich nicht dass wir heute
hier stehen
aber was wir wussten robert und ich und
viele andere ist dass wir unsere partei
öffnen wollen dass wir politik für die
breite der gesellschaft machen wollen
einladend und mit klaren zielen und so
beginnt heute ein neues kapitel für
unsere partei
und wenn wir es gut machen auch für
unser land
wir haben eine klare idee einer
kanzlerschaft für deutschland ich möchte
heute hier mit meiner kandidatur ein
angebot machen für die gesamte
gesellschaft als einladung unser
vielfältiges starkes reiches land in
eine gute zukunft zu führen
dafür sind so ehrlich müssen wir seinen
veränderungen nötig und wir können diese
veränderungen wir müssen sie aber auch
machen
wir müssen sie machen für ein gerechtes
land in dem kitas und schulen wirklich
die schönsten orte sind ein land in dem
pflegekräfte wirklich zeit und vor allem
ressourcen haben sich um die menschen zu
kümmern
ein land in dem der staat digital
funktioniert und seinen bürgerinnen und
bürgern dient ein diverses und
weltoffenes land werte basiert und eine
wehrhafte demokratie in deutschland im
herzen europas
ein land in dem klimaschutz das
zukünftige fundament schafft für
wohlstand freiheit und sicherheit ein
klimaschutz der auch die pendlerin
auf dem land mit denkt ein klimaschutz
für alleinerziehende mit geringem
einkommen für industriearbeiter damit
wir alle gut leben können ich war an
diesem historischen abend der pariser
klimakonferenz in paris mit dabei als
laurent fabius damalige französische
außenminister und chefverhandler der
pariser klimakonferenz an diesem abend
seine holzhammer namen und sagte das
abkommen ist angenommen
da standen menschen die sich
logischerweise nicht kannten
delegierte aus 194 ländern mit tränen in
den augen im raum und fielen sich in die
arme
vor fünf jahren müssen uns die zeit noch
mal vorstellen zwar moment wo so viele
gezweifelt und gehadert haben können wir
wirklich die großen großen
herausforderung unserer zeit lösen
endlich wieder ein großes
internationales abkommen zu schaffen und
ich stand in diesen ganzen getöse und
neben ja meine kleine tochter sechs
monate alt in ihrem kinderwagen und ich
dachte so wenn sie so alt ist wie ich
heute 35 im jahr 2050 das ja für das
diese klimakonferenz seine großen ziele
formuliert hat dann wird sie vielleicht
auch kleine kinder haben dann bin ich
großmutter
dann werden wir klimagerechten wohlstand
geschaffen haben müssen
klimaschutz ist die aufgabe unserer zeit
die aufgabe meiner generation und
entsprechend will ich dass die politik
einer neuen bundesregierung klimaschutz
für alle bereiche zum maßstab macht um
paris zu erfüllen
für all das braucht es jetzt mut dinge
wirklich anders zu machen
zukunft ist nichts was einfach so
passiert wir haben es in der hand und
deshalb stehe ich heute hier was alles
nicht geht das haben wir jetzt in den
letzten jahren genug gehört
aber es zählt jetzt war
alles geht was alles möglich ist und
genau diesen anspruch das hat robert
habe gerade ja noch mal deutlich gemacht
dieses angebot haben wir gemeinsam in
den letzten jahren in unsere partei
getragen aber eben auch ins land
getragen verändern statt zu versprechen
jetzt ist die zeit in diesem sinne eine
gute regierung anzuführen und politik
jedenfalls so wie ich politik erlebe
wirkt immer im konkreten im konkreten
für die menschen für die menschen in
ihrer vielfalt in ihrer
unterschiedlichkeit und deswegen müssen
wir politik auch aus dem konkreten
heraus machen an so vielen orten in
unserem land gibt es so viele beispiele
und das neue schon realität ist die
gesundheitsregion gerade auch in
ländlichen regionen wo pflegekräfte wo
ärztinnen und ärzte therapeuten zusammen
arbeiten um in der fläche alle gut zu
versorgen
die kommune die tatsächlich schon zu 100
prozent erneuerbaren energien sich
versorgt die schule die komplett
digitalisiert ist und dann noch eine
schulküche und der musikverein mit an
ort an bord hat es geht es geht aber all
das funktioniert nur weil ausnahmen von
festgefahrenen alten regeln geschaffen
wurden
in diesem ausnahme modus allein kommen
wir aber nicht weiter
es gilt jetzt neue regeln zu schaffen
und zwar so dass das fortschrittliche
dass das beste nicht die ausnahme ist
sondern der zukünftige standard in
unserem europa steckt so wahnsinnig viel
so viele menschen bringen sich ein mit
ihrer innovation mit ihrer leidenschaft
mit ihrem mut und mit ihrer tatkraft
ich will dass wir all das entfesseln
dass wir das beste was in diesem land
steckt auch wirklich möglich machen
für die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
europäischen industrie für unseren
mittelstand vor unserer handwerker und
für eine lebendige kultur
dafür müssen wir investieren
in forschung und den sozialen
zusammenhalt in polizeiwachen und
gerichtssäle in die digitale verwaltung
und ein schnelles internet und all das
verlangt veränderung und diese
veränderung ist aber nur möglich wenn
wir auch eine andere politische kultur
pflegen in der man sich wertschätzt
kritische stimmen ernst nimmt und nicht
gegeneinander arbeitet sondern
miteinander eine grüne kanzlerin
kandidatur steht für ein neues
verständnis von politischer führung
entschieden und transparent lernfähig
und selbstkritisch demokratie lebt vom
wechsel ja ich war noch die kanzlerin
auch noch nicht ministerin
ich trete an für erneuerungen für den
status quo stehen andere
ich bin zutiefst davon überzeugt dass
dieses land einen neuanfang braucht um
gut durch dieses neue herausfordernde
jahr zehn zu kommen
mit diesem auf sicht fahren das haben
wir aber schon immer so gemacht und wenn
es dann doch sein muss dann drehen wir
halt noch ein stellschräubchen weiter da
kommen wir nicht weiter ich möchte
anbieten eine politik die vorausschau
auf die was neues wagt die den menschen
zuhört und ihnen aber auch wirklich was
zutraut eine politik die bei aller
notwendigkeit auch harte entscheidungen
zu treffen
menschlich und empathisch bleibt ich
komme aus einer generation die nicht
mehr jung ist aber auch nicht alt einer
generation die in einem geeinten
deutschland und in einem gemeinsamen
europa erwachsen geworden ist das
fundament auf dem wir stehen haben
generationen vor uns hart erarbeitet wir
haben jetzt die aufgabe das gute das
beste in die zukunft zu tragen
die verbundenheit der generation ist für
mich grundlage für eine starke
gesellschaft jugendliche die in panini
zeiten auf ihre frei
auf ihre nähe eigentlich auf alles was
es ausmacht jung zu sein verzichtet
haben um ältere menschen zu schützen
großeltern die in sorge oster nicht
erleben zu können jetzt endlich frisch
geimpft ihre enkelkinder wieder sehen
können und manche von ihnen morgens ihr
enkelkind für die schule testen
rentnerin demonstrieren mit teenagern
für klimaschutz weil es sie eben nicht
kalt lässt wie die nachbarskinder in 30
jahren leben
das ist gelebte solidarität und in
diesem sinne mache ich politik
ich weiß wie groß die verantwortung ist
wie hoch die erwartungen an uns und auch
an mich das was da kommt hat robert
habeck bereits gesagt das wird uns als
partei gehörig fordern
es wird nicht immer leicht sein aber wir
gehen das gemeinsam an nicht nur robert
habeck und ich nicht nur wir als bündnis
grünen bündnis 90 die grünen insgesamt
sondern vor allen dingen als eine
gesellschaft die so viel weiter ist als
die politik die größte kraft die
entwickelt man immer nur zusammen
viele sind in diesem jahr der pandemie
erschöpft in spannung in der
gesellschaft es gibt natürlich
widerstreitende unterschiedlicher
interessen aber es gibt halt so viele
die bereit sind verantwortung zu
übernehmen
auch über ihr eigenes wohl hinaus die
eigentlich gestalten wollen
in deutschland steckt so viel
wir haben das auto erfunden und das
fahrrad die energiewelt revolutioniert
wir haben gemeinsam unter größtem druck
bin kürzester zeit ein impfstoff
entwickelt
jeden tag setzten sich menschen setzen
sich lehrerin und pfleger forscherin und
landwirte ehrenamtlich für diese
gesellschaft ein jeden tag wachsen sie
über sich hinaus
jetzt ist es an der zeit dass politik
über sich hinauswächst
das hier zukunft gestalten das ist mein
angebot
das ist unser angebot dafür treten wir
an
[Musik]
so das war also anna-lena werbe ob die
entscheidung ist gefallen
sie wird die kanzlerkandidatin der
grünen robert habeck können wir da
vorgesehen
er sagt kooperationen und miteinander
das ist der neue führungsstil ein
anderes politikverständnis dafür stehen
die grünen und folgerichtig haben sie
sich dann für annalena baerbock
entschieden nach langen gesprächen die
auch durchaus so habe ich das verstanden
auch kontrovers waren aber am ende eben
doch eine einheitliche entscheidung
stand und das ganze wie gesagt sehr
geräuschlos annalena baerbock neues
kapitel für die partei wenn wir es gut
machen sagt sie dann auch ein neues
kapitel für das land veränderungen sind
nötig für gerechtigkeit für kitas pflege
digital ist eine wehrhafte demokratie
und natürlich vor allem den klimaschutz
das natürlich die zentrale aufgabe der
grünen nach wie vor aber eben auch mit
anderen themen angereichert und wir
sprechen weiter mit nicole diekmann
unserer zdf hauptstadtkorrespondenten
also die katze ist aus dem sack
wie hat frau baerbock auf mich gewirkt
naja also sie hat sichtlich versucht
diesen wechsel für den sie steht nochmal
in den vordergrund zu schieben und hat
da das fand ich sehr interessant
ein argument derjenigen die sich in den
vergangenen wochen gegen sie
positioniert hatten als mögliche
kanzlerkandidaten der grünen für sich
umzumünzen versucht die hat nämlich
gesagt ja ich war noch nie kanzlerin ich
habe noch nie regiert ich stehe für
einen wechsel das ist also ihr großes
manko das wird der politische gegner
vermutlich im wahlkampf auch gegen sie
verbänden zu verwenden versuchen dass
sie eben keinerlei regierungserfahrung
besitzt sie waren die kanzlerin sie war
aber auch noch die bürgermeisterin sie
war noch nie ministerpräsidenten sie hat
eben keinerlei regierungserfahrung und
da hat sie jetzt eben versucht in die
offensive zu gehen und zu sagen na ja im
grunde spricht das ja auch für mich
ich verkörpere den wechsel durch und
durch ich bin jemand die wirklich völlig
unverbraucht ist durch regierungsämter
ich stehe komplett auch als person mit
meiner biografie verein wechsel den wir
als grüne anstreben das ist ein wagnis
ist das im prinzip aber auch die einzige
chance die sie sozusagen hat mit ihrer
nicht regierung
erfahrung dann auch derart offensiv
umzugehen und immer wieder klar zu
machen
das land steht vor einer zäsur ist muss
ein neuanfang geben mit dem bewährten
kommen wir nicht weiter gerade im thema
klima natürlich dann fahren wir den
karren irgendwann an die wand also es
muss eine zäsur geben ist das ihre
chance
das ist auf jeden fall eine der chancen
auf die sie offensichtlich setzt was
auch noch mal ausgefallen es gerade in
ihrer rede ist dass sie ihre ihre
mutterrolle ihre kinder betont hat die
ist mutter zweier kleiner kinder das hat
sie auch noch mal gesagt sie hat sich
auch in den vergangenen monaten während
dieser krise immer wieder auch mit
dieser persönliche note in die
diskussion eingemischt jan hat gesagt
also ich weiß was in den kitas hier los
ist ich weiß was in den schulen hier los
ist das war ja gerade eine rede das hat
es ja auch betont die grünen treten
nicht nur an um programmatisch den
wechsel herbeizuführen sondern sagt
annalena baerbock wir wollen auch das
politische miteinander verändern
wir wollen eine politische kultur der
wertschätzung schaffen und das ist das
ist natürlich das wofür sie jetzt stehen
will und eben das fand ich sehr
interessant
du hast es eben schon gesagt sie hat
natürlich als grüner den klimaschutz in
den vordergrund gerückt das hat sie aber
getan indem sie bei diesem programmpunkt
in ihrer aufzählung am längsten
geblieben ist begonnen hat sie aber die
die auflistung der punkte die sich die
grünen als besonders wichtig jetzt im
wahlkampf geben haben mit kitas und
schulen und das glaube ich das wird sie
versuchen ganz deutlich für sich zu
nutzen eben nicht nur eine frau zu sein
und eben unverbraucht zu sein als noch
nie in regierungsverantwortung da
gewesen sondern eben auch als eine als
eine mutter die mitten im leben steht
die tagtäglich zu hause versuchen
miterlebt was die einschränkungen was
die korona maßnahmen bedeuten und die
eben auch in normalen zeiten ja wenn wir
gerade keine pandemie haben im leben
steht weil sie eben zwei kleine kinder
zu hause hat um die sie sich kümmern
muss neben ihrer arbeit als politikerin
also sie hat verschiedene aspekte
angesprochen eine durchaus integrative
rede also weg muss man ja auch sagen
jetzt von der
umwelt klientel partei sondern das ist
nun denke ich auch noch mal so wenn man
sich für die kanzlerschaft wird dann
muss man ja verschiedene interessen da
eben auch ansprechen also du hast das
gesagt auch hin zum sozialen vor allem
ist das schon ein möglicher wink in
richtung naja potenzielle
koalitionsgespräche so weit sind wir
natürlich noch nicht aber das sozusagen
schon mal die konstellation so ein
bisschen ausgelotet wird mit wem könnte
man überhaupt mit wem wäre eine grüne
kanzlerschaft denkbar
naja also die grünen sind ja mit
annalena baerbock und robert habeck zum
erst mal in ihrer geschichte mit zwei
real los an der parteiführung die
letzten jahre gewesen
wir erinnern uns es gab eigentlich immer
die paritätische verteilung zwischen den
sogenannten fundis und den realo das ist
vorbei und das zeigt sich auch daran
dass man sich noch einigermaßen offen
hält und sich nicht festlegen will mit
wem man sich eine koalition vorstellen
kann das wäre auch ziemlich schwierig in
anbetracht der verhältnisse der
mehrheitsverhältnisse die wir im moment
in umfragen sehen da ist vieles möglich
und vieles ist auch nicht möglich und es
ist auch noch ein halbes jahr hin und
das wird dafür muss man wirklich nicht
hellseherisch begabt sein das wird ein
sehr turbulentes jahr sein halbes jahr
lang bis dahin wir warten mal ab wie
schmutzig dieser wahlkampf wird das
heißt das hat man an der rede auch
gemerkt die war sehr freundlich dazu
gewandt die war aber auch nicht sehr
konkret
das ist logisch ist heute erst mal darum
wer ist eigentlich die kandidatin aber
diese rede war schon sehr bewusst so
offen gehalten
thematisch da hat man mal einmal den
rundumschlag gemacht dass man jetzt mit
dieser rede nicht sagen kann aha also
wohnungsbaupolitik mieten deckel das
sind klare signale auf diese themen ist
anna lena berger gerade überhaupt nicht
eingegangen
das wäre ein klares signal in richtung
gewesen wir haben ja hier in berlin
letzte woche erlebt wieder von
rot-rot-grün hier
der regierende senat ist ja rot rot grün
beschlossene mieten decke gekippt worden
ist also das wäre das wäre ein mögliches
werk auf bundesebene
wie gesagt das hat sie familien man hält
sich da fast alle optionen offen was
natürlich klar ist dass man mit der ard
nicht koalieren wird aber das gilt ja
für alle anderen parteien im bundestag
auch also ansonsten deiner einschätzung
nach noch keine klare politische
präferenz oder gar signal
an andere parteien in welche richtung
das gehen könnte
war vielleicht heute auch nicht zu
erwarten nach heinz locher schreibt uns
über facebook bisher die beste
kandidatin für den job die jungen müssen
an die führungen oder wir machen weiter
wie bisher und fahren den karren an die
wand so seine meinung die tabletten über
youtube verdammt gute rede schließt
einfach mal ein bisschen vor michaela
potter-filme youtube großartige rede sie
spitze also zumindest bei einigen kam
die rede gut an
dann vielleicht gerade ich hatte es
schon versucht david wilhelms über
youtube die grünen können es ja locker
angehen da die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
sie einen kanzler stellen müssen nicht
realistisch ist also warum darum ringen
dieser einschätzung würde ich mich jetzt
nicht unbedingt anschließend nach dem
was wir momentan so erleben auch bei der
politischen konkurrenz wie siehst du das
das sehe ich genauso einmal genau weil
bei dem was wir bei der politischen
konkurrenz erleben dann wenn man sich
die mehrheitsverhältnisse anguckt und
ein wichtiger dritter punkt ist auch die
dynamik also wir leben in einem
absoluten ausnahmezustand im moment wir
leben in einer pandemie wir leben immer
noch mit vielen politisch back liegen
fragen impfung ganz aktuell die bundes
notbremse hat die bestand hat die nicht
bestand fällt dann wird die groko
krachend unterstützt sie damit krachend
beides von gerichten dann doch wieder
gekippt wird
das ist doch viel zeit mit die umfragen
können sich noch in viele richtungen
drehen man weiß nicht wie entschlossen
die union ist in ihrem
selbstzerfleischung prozess also da
würde ich jetzt erstmal nicht davon
ausgehen dass die grünen da völlig
chancenlos sind
was das kanzleramt an geht nicht also
würde ich auch denken nachdem was man
momentan ebenso zur kenntnis nimmt sind
zumindest mal die chancen halbwegs
intakt vielen dank für diese
einschätzungen nicole diekmann war dass
unsere zdf hauptstadtkorrespondenten
belieben vielen dank und auch daher
natürlich an euch für eure beteiligung
vielleicht noch mal der hinweis dass wir
auch gerade die nachricht bekommen haben
dass csu-chef söder heute nochmal sich
vor die presse stellen wird also bei der
union werden sie einfach angesprochen
ist das rennen ja offenbar noch nicht
entschieden und da gibt es also heute
eine pressekonferenz und zwar um 14 uhr
wenn ich richtig weiß ich frage gerade
noch mal nach bei der regie
so und jetzt höre ich gerade dass wir
noch ein stück spielen wollen dann
machen wir das doch und ich nehme an es
handelt sich dabei noch mal auf den oder
um den rückblick besser gesagt auf die
grünen und auf ihre parteigeschichte 40
jahre werden es werden auch angesprochen
da ist einiges passiert in dieser zeit
und das wollen wir uns gerade noch mal
anschauen strickpullis zigaretten
vollbärte die grünen wollten frischen
wind in das parteiensystem bringen
1980 schnell bei dem gründungs beschluss
in karlsruhe gut tausend hände in die
höhe
mit dabei christen kommunisten
wertkonservative am anfang stand der
protest gegen atomkraft gegen krieg 1983
ziehen die grünen in den bundestag für
umweltschutz und frieden
der spd vorsitzende willy brandt
gratuliert joschka fischer wird 1985 in
hessen zum ersten grünen minister
vereidigt in turnschuhen jeans und sport
sakko damals undenkbar 1993 schließen
sich die grünen mit dem bündnis 90 aus
ostdeutschland zusammen und plötzlich
will man keine protestpartei mehr sein
wo wir im wesentlichen protestpartei
waren so wichtig sie war diese zeit ist
mit der deutschen einheit endgültig zu
ende gegangen
1998 sind sie ganz oben die grünen
regieren als juniorpartner mit spd
kanzler gerhard schröder nach 16 jahren
kohl der beginn einer neuen ära
aber die partei ist zerrissen die
fundamentalisten sind von dem
realpolitischen ansatz nicht begeistert
heute hört man von solch internen
kämpfen nur noch wenig was bleibt ist
der wille zur macht und dieses mal
könnte es die einstige protestpartei
nach ganz oben schaffen und den kanzler
oder die kanzlerin stellen also da war
der moderator jetzt etwas voreilig wir
wollen natürlich auch gerne noch mal ein
bisschen über die grünen insgesamt
sprechen und gott sei dank ist meine
kollegin nicole diekmann auch noch da
und kann also mit uns tun also habe
gerade noch mal zurück geblickt auf die
grünen und die parteigeschichte ja muss
man ja schon sagen eine bewegte
geschichte vom strickpulli immerhin was
außenministerium und gegebenenfalls dann
auch demnächst ins kanzleramt was fällt
dir spontan dazu ein wenn du diesen
bilderbogen dann noch einmal zur
kenntnis nimmt heute noch nicht
besprochen haben ist ja es geht
natürlich um die kanzlerschaft und
annalena baerbock wird einigermaßen
ärgert sich sein sonst schafft man es
nicht
zur parteivorsitzenden aber auch wenn
die grünen nicht die kanzlerin stellen
sollten ist es im moment wenn man sich
die umfragen anguckt schwer möglich eine
regierung ohne die grünen überhaupt zu
bilden
das bedeutet dass man bei den grünen
natürlich auch jetzt realistischer weise
anfängt spätestens jetzt zu überlegen
welche ministerien man sich gerne
greifen würde und das hatten wir ja auch
gerade im beitrag das ist nun das ist
ein langer weg gewesen aber wir hatten
auch schon den grünen außenminister
joschka fischer
also von daher wäre das ein comeback
zurück an den koalitionstisch an den
kabinettstisch teuer
das stimmt und welche ministerien
glaubst du würden die grünen in diesem
fall anstreben also wann hat auch zum
beispiel ja schon mal gehört dass robert
habeck sicher auch für finanzen stark
interessiert dass das natürlich ein
schlüssel ressort ist also wäre das
denkbar
denkbar ist im moment alle ist das sagen
mit einem mit einem gequälten
gesichtsausdruck im moment auch
hochrangige unionspolitiker
bei denen ist ja gerade die hölle los
und das bedeutet eben auch dass im
moment alles und nichts möglich ist es
ist komplett schwierig vorherzusagen wer
da irgendwas
wem regiert wird es eine schwarz grüne
regierung wird es eine grün schwarze
regierung sollte eine kombination aus
grünen und union zustande kommen dann
sitzen da drei parteien am tisch damit
die csu auch wort mitzureden haben ist
bis dahin bei söder bis dahin der
spitzenkandidat wie stark ist dann die
union die csu da vertreten wie schwach
ist dann die cdu oder umgekehrt schafft
laschet ist vermutlich diese woche noch
sich durchzusetzen dann sind die karten
auch wieder neu gemischt was klar ist
ist natürlich werden die grünen das
umweltministerium für sich beanspruchen
alles andere wäre ja großer klamauk und
annalena baerbock werden auch ambitionen
aufs außenministerium nachgesagt sie ist
ja europapolitikern karen hat ja auch
das thema eu kann man heute in ihrer
rede angesprochen
aber wie gesagt es ist im moment der
nassen diffus langjährige unions
berichterstatter innen reiben sich die
augen verlieren was sie gerade sehen
hätten das nicht für möglich gehalten
deswegen jetzt prognosen zu wagen also
ich wette gerne aber heute will ich auch
gar nichts retten
gut dann wollen wir dich nicht dazu
verleiten aber vielleicht trotzdem noch
mal ganz interessant die nachfrage
glaubst du denn dass es aus grünen sicht
jetzt einen klaren favoriten gibt wen
die union aufstellen sollte also anders
gefragt wäre ein wahlkampf für die
grünen gegen laschet oder söder
einfacher oder eben schwieriger
tja das ist eine große frage also söder
ist ja votiert quasi von jemandem der
von asyl tourismus sprach noch vor
wenigen jahren zu einem baum um aber wie
das immer so schön heißt hat er den
bienenschutz für sich in bayern als
ministerpräsident entdeckt den
umweltschutz und mal ernsthaft zu sagen
der ist lebendig ich glaube dass man
sich aus grünen sicht besser abarbeiten
könnte an einem markus söder dass der
mehr offene pflanzen bietet nicht nur
für die grüne im übrigen eben durch
diese sagen wir's mal flexibilität die
ich gerade auch angesprochen habe in
seinen positionen
diese flanke bietet abi laschet nicht an
die lasche würde aber eine andere flanke
bieten die ist hausgemacht in der union
armin laschet wäre ein politiker der
sich mit mühe und not als cdu-chef
durchsetzen konnte gegen markus söder
das heißt er wäre sehr geschwächt würde
der in den wahlkampf gehen
zusammengefasst macht die union es den
grünen im moment einfacher wobei man
aber auch nicht vergessen darf dass die
union lustigerweise vergangene woche in
den umfragen ein bisschen zugelegt hat
also die aufmerksamkeit ist gerade groß
unterm strich sind beide kandidaten im
moment und es martialisch auszusprechen
leichte beute für die politischen gegner
und wie ist das im verhältnis zu olaf
scholz ja das wird auch noch mal
interessant natürlich sind die grünen
und die spd so was wie natürliche
partner
ja und man steht sich natürlich in
vielen positionen auch näher als sich
union und die grünen stehen jetzt haben
ja gerade von annalena baerbock in ihrer
rede gehört und so war die rede auch ich
glaube es gab zwei momente in denen sie
mal so versteckt kritik an der jetzigen
regierung geübt hat und das sehr sehr
vorsichtig das eine war da sagte sie was
alles nicht geht haben wir in den
vergangenen jahren gehört und mit diesem
auf sicht fahren kommen wir nicht weiter
das war also versteckte kritik an der
groko vor allem auch in der pandemie da
sieht man schon so wie viele attacken
sich die grünen überhaupt hinreißen
lassen wollen in diesem wahlkampf also
die scheinen wenn sie das durchhalten
dann auch ernstzumachen in diesem
angestrebten wechsel was auch die
politische debattenkultur angeht das
heißt wir müssen uns da sowieso auch
eine andere art der der wahlkampfführung
einstellen vielleicht nennt man das
hybride wahlkampfführung aber die
reibungsfläche ist nicht so groß bei
olaf scholz die bietet der aber
natürlich auch olaf scholz ist auch wenn
die spd in vergangenen monaten ja die
eine oder andere absetzbewegung versucht
hat de facto ist der vizekanzler er
sitzt mit in der
wo es an allen entscheidungen beteiligt
gewesen auch was das pandemie geschehen
angeht
und insofern wird er im rahmen der
verlegen grünen gewünschten
möglichkeiten auch ein fast flächen
bieten vor allem hat frau berger
schreibt uns elke jockenhövel vor allem
hat sie eine ganze partei hinter sich
die sie unterstützen wird im gegensatz
zu frau merkel so ihre meinung die 16
jahre lang von ihrer eigenen partei im
stich gelassen wurde ist das so hat frau
bernburg in der partei erst mal alle
hinter sich kann man davon ausgehen das
wird die große und spannende frage sein
in den kommenden monaten wir sind ja
alle sehr überrascht dass es tatsächlich
geklappt hat ich glaube bis 11 uhr drei
habe ich mir aufgeschrieben haben die
grünen ist tatsächlich geschafft es
nicht auszusprechen dass annalena
baerbock kanzlerkandidatin wird es war
ein bisschen klar als harbeck
anzusprechen dass er sich selber jetzt
nicht zum kanzlerkandidaten wird
ausrufen können da konnte man schon an
aber nochmal die grünen haben es
geschafft in dieser aufgeregten super
neugierigen und auch an durchstechereien
ja sehr interessierten berliner republik
dieses geheimnis bis zum schluss zu
hüten
die haben komplett die kontrolle
behalten
deswegen bei allem misstrauen die wir
alle nutzen das wir natürlich alle gegen
die wir uns schon seit längerer zeit mit
politik beschäftigen könnte es
tatsächlich möglich sein dass sich die
partei hinter annalena baerbock
gesammelt das muss sie annalena baerbock
hat ein großes versprechen abgegeben
also es ist ja ein großes wort zu sagen
wir wollen auch die politische
debattenkultur verändern das müssen die
grünen jetzt vormachen ja daran wird sie
gemessen werden und beziehst du
wahrscheinlich auch ausdrücklich robert
habeck mit einem der natürlich jetzt
auch nachdem die entscheidung gefallen
ist ja nicht mehr quer schießen sollte
das darf er nicht dass daran nicht
das würde sowohl die grünen mit in den
abgrund reißen als auch annalena
baerbock
das hat er das weiß er auch damit hat er
seine rede ja begonnen also eher und
annalena baerbock hätten in den
vergangenen jahren einen neuen
führungsstil und ein mit ein
etabliert in der partei er hat
versprochen bevor er also er sagte dass
annalena baerbock jetzt ins renn zieht
für seine partei hat er das auch
versprochen dass er seine erfahrung dem
punkt musste aber noch mal machen das
ist ja sein vorteil gegenüber berbalk
seine erfahrung auch aus
koalitionsverhandlungen die er früher
auch als umweltminister und als
stellvertretender ministerpräsident in
schleswig holstein hatte einbringen wird
auch in diesem wahlkampf also nochmal
beide haben heute ein großes versprechen
abgeliefert vor einer ich denke mal
breiten interessierten öffentlichkeit
und das müssen sie halten das ist ja
relativ schnell zu belegen wenn man
dieses versprechen bricht dann
schließlich mit den worten von oliver
krügel über facebook ich bin dafür dass
harald lesch bundeskanzler wird und dann
geht es voran und anna lena wird grüne
ministerin
das wäre es ja unser zdf
wissenschaftsjournalist also ich weiß
nicht ob das so kommt wahrscheinlich
eher nicht aber annalena baerbock
ebenfalls hat jetzt zumindest ganz gute
karten im rennen um das kanzleramt so
wollen wir gleich mal festhalten
vielen dank nochmal für diese
einschätzungen danke nochmal an euch und
noch mal kurz der hinweis 14 uhr wie
gesagt die pressekonferenz mit markus
söder auch da sind wir sehr gespannt was
da herauskommt ob denn da schon ein
ergebnis eine entscheidung getroffen
worden ist vielen dank bis hierhin und
euch erstmal eine gute zeit bis nachher
hoffentlich zschau